DNS is a distributed directory.
Around the world there
are several root servers
which direct requests to top
level domain servers, like for
dot com, which in turn direct requests
to the servers for particular domains.
This means that no one DNS server
needs to know all the records for
all the names and domains in the world.
The records for
a particular domain, like an A record
for www.greenspaceghost.com,
will be found in the authoritative
name servers for that domain.
Like the nameserver for
greenspaceghost.com,
which are listed in NS records for
the higher level zone.
So the NS record for greenspaceghost.com
will reside in the nameservers for
com or dot com, either way.
com and org and edu and net and a few
others are global top-level domains, or
gTLD's.
And their NS records are stored
in the root servers.
To make it faster, and more complicated,
the DNS server that the client to
resolve talks to isn't some
sort of global master server.
Resolvers normally talk to
a nearby caching DNS server.
For a home user, that might be the local
home router, or it might be run by their
ISP, or it could be a well known
DNS service like Google Public DNS.
When that catching server
receives a query from a client,
first it consults its local cache.
If the cache doesn't
know what the record is,
the caching server recursively
resolves the query,
forwarding to
the appropriate nameservers.
Possibly first at the root and
then at the top level domain, and
then at the lower level domain until
eventually it gets back an answer.
Then it stores that
result in its cache so
it doesn't have to run
the same query over and
over again every time you look up
audacity.com or google.com or whatever.
And finally, it's able to return
that result to the client.
But caching can cause problems.
If you want to move your site
from one IP address to another,
like if you're moving your website
from Google to Amazon, and
some DNS cache has the old address,
then clients who use that cache will see
the old address instead of the new one.
To cut down on this kind of thing DNS
records have a time to live, or TTL,
which tells caches how
long to cache them for.
For instance, these records
that I just used dig to get for
udacity.com have a time
to live of 60 seconds.
If I look them up from the cache later,
the time to live is reduced.
Now it's down to 22 seconds, and 14.
And after the TTL expires,
caching servers have to go back to
the authoritative server again,
look the record up, to make sure
that their information is fresh.